بصراحة ما يعتقده الآخرون
فرق أو حتى الناس حولها
من الفريق
لن أقول إنني لا أهتم ولكن
اليوم نحن في فقاعة
نحن في فندقنا نحن نركز
قلت أن الفرقة كانت تعيش بشكل جيد
هدفنا هو تمرير
الجولة الأولى للفوز وماذا في ذلك
يعتقد أن الصحافة البلجيكية أو حتى
الناس من حولنا في الحد ليس كذلك
مشكلتي جئنا في مهمة
نحن نركز على اللاعبين
تتركز اليوم المفضلة هي
بلجيكا سواء أعجبك ذلك أم لا
إنهم على حق لديهم مدرب
رائع لديهم لاعبون من
أعلى مستوى في العالم عندما أرى De
Bruyne عندما أرى فرصة عندما كنت
انظر vitezel حزمة الجليد على batshuay
Lukaku لحسن الحظ هم كذلك
المفضلة ولديهم الخبرة التي لديهم
حتى لو ذهبنا سنكون شوفينيًا بعض الشيء
أعتقد أن لدينا أفضل حارس مرمى في
العالم ولكن على الصعيد العالمي هو مهذب
لذا
هم مفضلون عليك قبولها عند
واحد هو أن عليك استدعاء قطة هناك
ويروج بلجيكا والصليب ونحن
يريد مفاجأة ذلك غدا
آمل أنهم لن يفعلوا ذلك بالضبط
الاحترام حتى نتمكن من إنشاء
مفاجأة هذا ما أقوله و
أعتقد أن كرواتيا إذا لم نفعل ذلك
المفاجأة هي أن لديهم منا
محترمة لأنهم كانوا مركزين
كانوا يعرفون أن لدينا جميلة
فريق لم يتركونا كثيرًا
من الفضاء وأعتقد أنه غدًا
بلجيكا سوف يحترموننا وهذا
ستكون مباراة صعبة للغاية بالنسبة لـ
فريقين